the Republic of Moldova knows what hard
times mean
but we also know when the power of unity
can achieve now only this kind of power
solidarity can protect lives and stand
up to Russia's brutal invasion of
Ukraine
the EU Ukraine solidarity Lanes work to
protect Global Food security sustain
economies and nourish the people as
Russia blocks the safe passage to and
from Ukrainian ports and endangers the
livelihoods of millions of people across
the world who rely on those agricultural
products we have to ensure the
continuous work of alternative routes
for transportation my country jointly
works with the EU Ukraine and other
International Partners to ensure the
good functioning of the solidarity Lanes
we efficiently facilitate the transit of
a significant number of tracks a huge
pressure for our Customs and Border
management
we have found Solutions on how to reduce
waiting times remove bottlenecks and
transform our borders into an open and
safe gate for essential products to and
from Ukraine
to improve the functioning of the
solidarity Lanes more support is needed
Moldova will continue to do its part
for the world
for its friends for its neighbors and
for what's right we want to open more
border crossings build more bridges with
Ukraine and Romania modernize the due to
lash port to increase its capacity adopt
our Railways to European standards to
facilitate faster Transit
but in times of Crisis like today we
need help and foreign investment for
such big infrastructure projects
moldovans stand up for others when in
need it is not only our duty as
Europeans it is Who We Are